hello and welcome to the final webinar
in a series of 13 on berry crop
nutrition and soil management these
webinars were developed for training
educators and commercial berry growers
the webinars were recorded as part of a
two-year northeast ser professional
development project led by dr. Marvin
Pritts small fruit horticulturalist and
berry crop nutrition specialist at
Cornell University the speakers for this
week's webinar are mr. Jeff Miller
Association issue leader from Cornell
Cooperative Extension and Ida County
Laura McDermott extension associate with
the Capital District vegetable and small
fruit program from Cornell University
and your host myself Kathy heidenreich
I'm extension support specialist with
Cornell University in the Department of
Horticulture the agenda for this week's
webinar apart from the introduction of
speakers which we've already done is
presentation and the topics of the
presentation will include an
introduction to Barry soil nutrient
management discussion of the basic soil
test pH modification and testing the
Cornell soil health test and tissue
analysis if you'd like to listen to the
other recorded webinars in the series
you may do so by going to the link below
down below in the files box you will see
there are several files that you can
download the very soil nutrient
management revision tube is a PDF of
this presentation there's a grower pre
and post-test you can take to test your
knowledge before and after the
presentation there's a chart that gives
you the desired ranges for foliar
analysis for strawberries blueberries
and raspberries and then the submission
forms for the standard Cornell soil
health test form I'm sorry the standard
tissue test form P or the Cornell soil
health test down below also listed over
in the web links box is again the link
for the recorded berry soil nutrient
management webinars and the Cornell
fruit resources Barry pages
and without further ado we will move to
the presentation screen and Jeff we're
ready for you now
thanks Kathy
I'm going to take a couple minutes in
the beginning part of this presentation
to talk to you a little bit about so
I'll testing soil sampling and we'll
start off
talking to you a little bit about
and tissue testing it's pretty hard to
manage a crop unless you have some
pieces of information to help you manage
that crop and that's really where soil
sampling soil testing and tissue testing
come in there's definitely two main
timeframes that we talk about when we
talk about sampling and that's pre
plants so if you're planting an
expensive crop like raspberries or
blueberries and you want to prepare the
soil beforehand so that you have the
least amount of obstacles and the most
optimum conditions for those expensive
crops is a great opportunity to take
soil tests and get analyses back and
have time to actually make some
adjustments and for these crops one of
the major things that you have to think
about is things like soil drainage as a
possibility getting irrigation to the
site as a second possibility but really
what we're talking about today is the
fertility management and one of the
things that you can change is pH if you
plan on doing a blueberry planting you
know that you want to get the pH down
into the force at least mid fours and if
you do not do a soil pH test in advance
of the planting then you're probably not
going to have enough time to modify that
pH and have it down in the range that's
optimal for that crop and the same would
be true in acid soils and bringing them
up to six or six five depending on
whether you're going to go with
raspberries or strawberries so it's a
real opportune time to take those
samples another time to think about soil
sampling is after the plantings already
in and this is the case where you're
talking about maintaining a viable stand
at optimal performance and taking
samples soil running them through a lab
and getting an analysis back and and
then making sure that there's no major
major shortages of any important
nutrients and if there are making sure
that you're applying those nutrients
inadequate
quantities to optimize both crop yield
and quality a last thing that bro should
consider is protecting the environment
so if you look at any sale to the
average grower how much do you play how
much do you apply and do you do soil
testing there's often enough times where
you hear the answer I don't really do an
awful lot of soil sampling but I make
sure that I never short the crop so that
means that there's a possibility that
there's over fertilization going on and
that can be very costly and depending on
the nutrient that could have some
environmental ramifications as well
now just talking to you about the the
basic types of testing the standard soil
test which is a chemical analysis the
Cornell soil health test and tissue
analysis if you look at a standard soil
test it's it's something that's
conducted at many labs across the states
and the attempt is to measure the
availability of essential nutrients for
plants so each lab has their own set up
their own procedures their own material
is used to leach out nutrients and
measurements taken on the quantity of
those nutrients that are then report
back to the growers in in New York State
Cornell has done an awful lot of field
research and done some tests to look at
what is in the soil and application
rates and the response the application
rates given different soil levels of
those nutrients so that's the basic
chemical analysis that people would get
reports back interpret them and adjust
their fertility and pH accordingly the
Cornell soil health test is a unique
test looking at some of the other
attributes of the soil and that's a
biological aspects and the physical
aspects of the soil and how they impact
plant growth and development and lower
is going to be talking to you about that
a little bit later in this presentation
and then finally tissue analysis this is
a great way to measure what actually the
plant is seeing in the way of nutrients
if you do soil tests you can see well
well this is what we have in the soil
but the tissue analysis tells you what
the plan is taking up from the soil and
Kathy is going to talk to you a little
bit more about that later
there's two basic times that you would
look at ad testing one is the routine
measurements you know if you have an
established planting you take samples
every three years you look at the
results you make some minor
modifications adding phosphorus when
it's needed are modifying the pH if it's
needed either down or up depending upon
the crop and or if you have a situation
where you have no history of sight at
all and you plan on putting a planting
of perennial berry like blueberries into
an area great opportunity to do that so
I'll test at that time that's more of
the routine types of tests that are
conducted there's definitely a chance to
use soil testing and fuller analysis to
do diagnostic work when plants are not
doing as well as you think they should
and it's just one piece of the
information that you can use to help
come up with answers for local growers
to actually identify what the problem is
on the site and usually this is done
with doing some paired sampling so
taking a series of samples in an area
that is just not performing up to par
and then comparing them with at least
the results of those chemical analyses
with an area of the field where you have
reasonable performance in these
situations adding soluble salts as an
analysis is probably an important thing
to do and using plant tissue analysis
just gives you that additional piece of
information that you can use in a
answering a battery of questions and
narrowing down the field to the the
problem
now it's important to look
how you would want obtain a sample in
the case of a problem identification you
can see that in it by the green arrow
there's an area of sweet corn in this
case it's not performing very well and
yet a majority of the rest of the
planting is doing very well this is an
opportunity to take some samples to
identify what the problem might be so in
sampling these areas you'd want to take
a series of samples from the area that's
not performing well and you should take
a minimum of eight sub-samples that are
then mixed together as a single sample
from both the problem area as well as
the area that's more representative of
good performance so that's one sampling
strategy another important thing to
consider when you're sampling is
actually to sample by management unit so
you can picture your farm and you can
picture block planting of that farm over
time you would want to first look at the
soil types that are underneath these
plantings and if there are major changes
in soil type to actually sample within
those soil types because there can be
very big differences in their ability to
hold on to nutrients the amount of lime
or sulfur that's needed to change the pH
depending on the texture differences
between those soil types so that's the
starting point but beyond that you may
have a planting of strawberries that's
newly planted and that should be sampled
separately then plantings that are two
and three years old and even within
those plantings maybe have different
varieties planted you should be
considering them as management units and
doing sampling separately for those
management units and then using it as a
diagnostic tool is is yet the other
method so talking about
a sampling of soils for chemical
analysis there are different labs they
use various extractants to estimate how
much plant available nutrients are in
that sample and yes the values that can
get from the same sample can be very
different from different labs and the
important thing to take home out of that
is not to take values from one lab
results and try to make recommendations
using another labs information so in New
York State their recommendation is to go
with Cornell soil sample analysis and
that is being conducted by a private
firm dairy one because then you get the
power of the University and all the
trials that are conducted in the
information gleaned from those trials
and the recommendations that come from
those trials
so agri one is the place to go in New
York State mainly because you get the
benefit of the Cornell recommendations
which are based on research results
there are a certain set of sampling
tools that can be used in obtaining soil
samples in the upper right you can see
series of those tools you have an order
soil probe head and you can see that
they're made from stainless steel one of
the one of the important things to avoid
is contamination of the sample so if you
use steel shovels spades to obtain the
sample and they haven't been cared for
and there's some rust on them that can
actually contaminate the sample another
thing to think about when you're taking
a sample is you're trying to be as
representative of the situation as
possible it is just a sample from the
field so getting to the same depth
consistently making sure you have the
same volume of soil that's obtained at
each site and then mixing each one of
the sub samples to come up with a
composite for an entire area all those
things give you good information if you
got too much sample from one site and
not enough from another now you're
actually weighing the sample results and
if you don't have sufficient number of
samples you can definitely have some
errors in the information that you're
going to get from the sample results
another thing to consider is to make
sure that you're using a plastic bucket
you know some buckets are made from zinc
and zinc can contaminate the sample as
well and the third thing is make sure
that you're using the appropriate forms
appropriate procedures in putting
together the sample to send it off to
the lab
now looking a little more closely at the
soil probe this is a favorite among a
lot of people and the reason why it's a
favorite is you have this tube that's
attached to a tee you can press this
into a soil get an ice core sample to
the depth that you're that you want to
go to clear this tube and then move on
to your next site so under good
conditions so that's not too wet not too
dry and definitely not rocky or gravely
you can do this very quickly and so a
lot of people use this particular device
to obtain samples I will say one of the
things that I do is whatever depth going
to for a specific crop I'll measure it
right on the probe and then I'll put a
piece of electrical tape around the tube
at that height so that I consistently go
to that same level looking at the order
the auger is a great tool under rocky
and wet conditions if it's too wet and
you use the soil probe anybody that's
done this you press it in the ground you
pull it back up and only half the tube
is actually filled because you actually
compress the soil when it was wet and
and you didn't get a full tube sort of
the sample so under wetter conditions
the soil actually adheres to the auger
and you just run your hand down the
order to clear that and you've got a
reasonable sample the same thing can be
done with the auger where you measure
let's say eight inches from the tip to
the top and make sure and put your
electrical tape there and then you know
that you're going to that depth
consistently another benefit of the
auger is that you can actually set them
up so that you can put them on a power
drill if you're doing a lot of samples
and some thought has gone into this
where people have cut a hole inside a
container like a bucket plastic bucket
and actually run the orbital into the
soil and bring it back up and they clear
it right there and
the samples trapped in the bucket so
pretty efficient way of sampling as was
mentioned before you definitely want to
take at least a minimum number of
samples to get a good representation of
any given area another thing that you
should consider is never do sampling and
let's say straight lines why is that
because a lot of times we are running in
straight lines up and down fields with
our equipment with fertilizer and
planting may be doing drainage work and
if you sample over that same area
consistently across the field you
actually are not representing all the
rest of the area and you may actually be
tainting the results so usually the
recommendation is to zig and zag across
an area to obtain a sample so that
you're getting a good representation of
the entire area to start sampling you
always remove the organic debris that's
at the surface because that will change
the results you make sure that you know
the depth at which you should be
sampling for the crop that you're
actually sampling for and it would
definitely be different depths for tree
fruits vs small fruits vs things like
field crops and turf grass so make sure
that you know the depth for the crop
that you're actually sampling for you
should definitely take eight to ten
sub-samples at a minimum in an area
anything less than two acres and
anything greater than two acres you
should have ten to twenty sub-samples
it's a minimum in larger acreages you
want at least a minimum of three
subsamples per acre for sampling for
berries both pre plant and established
plantings you want to go down to eight
inch depth and then in establish
plantings you want to pair up the soil
sample results with tissue analysis and
Kathy I'll talk to you a little bit more
about that later additional guidelines
remember to remove that
organic matched to go to death that's
recommended taking each subsample
putting it into the plastic bucket at
the end of sampling a particular area
mix well because now that is going to
represent that area and then you sub
sample from it to get your sample to
send off to the lab if the sample is too
wet then put it on something like a
plastic plates put a fan on it to air
dry it avoid using any kind of heat
source because that can definitely see
you the results especially nitrogen and
then make sure that you put it in the
appropriate container for the lab that
you're sending it to and make sure that
your forms are completely filled out
because they use that information in
making the recommendations in New York
State they have mapped the soils out
they've actually done in the hole us but
they use the soil names in new york
state to provide information about yield
capacity of the site and some of the
physical attributes of the soil and its
ability to hold onto nutrients so it's
important to put the soil series name on
the form indicating for the area that
you're sampling for your crop because
that is a valuable piece of information
that adds into the recommendation fact
you won't get a recommendation without
having that information on the form so
you can go online and use web soil
survey dot NRCS dot USDA dot-gov and get
the soil survey for your farm and then
specifically get down to the field level
and indicate what soil series name is
most predominant in the field or the
area that you're intending to sample
there's actually an iphone app and you
can get this from this presentation and
actually use that to find the soil name
for your particular location and or if
you don't want to go either those routes
you can go to a Cooperative Extension
Office often they have copies of the
same materials and can help you to
identify the soil name for your field
interpreting the results can be
challenging if you go to an out-of-state
lab they might send you results back
just indicating the pounds of particular
nutrients that are tested in the sample
and no recommendations and that's why
it's important to really use the lab
that's in your state that is associated
with a local land grant institution and
can provide recommendations just a
simple thing like checking your soil pH
you definitely have to have the
information ahead of time that if you're
growing strawberries or raspberries at
the pH that is recommended that's
optimal for those crops is between 6.2
and 6.5 versus blueberries much lower at
4.22 4.5 you look at the results and say
okay are my macro nutrients do they fall
into the medium range or above and if
not then I need to make some adjustments
and then here's the recommendation on
the soil sample results what's your soil
organic matter content for most berry
crops it's recommended to have three
percent or higher and again this is one
of those things if you test the site
beforehand you have a chance to actually
build up organic matter levels if you
need to the calcium levels are very
important for blueberry production and
the recommendation is when you're
looking at a Cornell soil test results
through Agri one that calcium be below
2,000 pounds per acre an aluminum can be
toxic at higher levels so if you see a
reading of 300 pounds of aluminum in
your sample per acre and then this is a
situation that you're going to have to
correct very quickly and that can occur
more and will occur more under acid
soils and definitely there's a
recommendation not to use any kind of
aluminum based fertilizers
you
so just a quick
about soil pH if you look at this graph
it's it's one that probably you've seen
before that indicates the availability
of some major necessary nutrients for
your plant growth and development and it
just shows the the wider the bands the
more available those nutrients are so
you can see that in the PH range of
let's say six to seven you find that
most nutrients have a high availability
as you go towards strongly acid the
availability of many nutrients falls off
and that can affect performance of your
plants or if the pH gets driven way up
you can have that same situation at
least for a series of these nutrients
that are necessary for crop growth and
development so it's very important for
you to understand that relationship and
how important it is to have the pH in
the soil at an optimal level for the
crop that you're growing
when you're modifying soil soil pH one
of the things that you should be aware
of is that it isn't instantaneous you
can't just apply lime to increase the pH
or sulfur to decrease the pH one day and
have the pH changed by the next day in
fact it's a long term process and takes
from six months to nine months to occur
um so this is better that you pre-plan
do the testing beforehand make
adjustments in the in pH through these
applications and do that nine months or
more in advance of actually planting the
intended crop and if you want more
information on this you can go to the
production guide for very crops put out
by n reis and this is what you might
expect this what you would get from
dairy one as far as a results form and
you can see that they have a nice
graphic in the upper right which shows
you very low low medium high and very
high levels of some of your major
macronutrients and you can see for
instance that phosphorus is in the low
medium level and probably would need to
be built up with additional applications
potassium is already high so pretty
reasonable calss when we talked about
that two thousand pounds of calcium per
acre being an indicator of at least
above that being a problem for blueberry
production pH 6.1 and looking at
strawberries as the intended crop where
you know close to the range that's
recommended and then organic matter we
talked about the fact that you wanted
three percent or more and in this case
you have four point six percent aluminum
we said that you had to have 300 pounds
per acre
or more to have problems with toxicity
from aluminium and it looks like we're
okay in this case nitrogen
recommendations from the sample a
hundred pounds of nitrogen total to be
split 80 pounds in july twenty pounds in
the following September and then 25
pounds of phosphorus fertilizer at
planting
and when it comes to bringing those
nutrient levels up to recommended levels
it's it's really the same the soil test
results will tell you okay you need so
many pounds of p 2 o 5 or K 20 potash or
phosphorus nitrogen and really it's when
you talk about organic versus
conventional is just the source that
you're changing so the percentage of
nutrients found in organic fertilizers
usually lower than those found in
conventional fertilizers but if you're
told to put on 30 pounds of nitrogen
then you just have to put on more
material of the organic type of
fertilizer to achieve the same 30 pounds
of nitrogen contribution to that crop
and you have to really really really
good guides the organic strawberry and
organic blueberry production guides to
help you find sources of fertilizers and
you know bring those soils up to spec
for optimal production of those crops
and with that I think I'm going to be
turning this over to Laura for further
discussion about the Cornell soil health
test all right thank you Jeff so we
talked a little bit about one aspect of
the Cornell soil health test which was
the chemical evaluation of the soil but
a higher level of testing involves
evaluation of biological and physical
properties of the soil in addition to
the chemical ones that Jeff explained
and those are measured in the sand
standard soil nutrient test all three of
the components biological physical and
chemical are interact to provide
conditions that could lead to optimal
plant performance chemical properties
are the most understood and they're the
easiest to modify of those three but we
can also influence soil physical and
biological properties
to in to enhance plant performance and
that's why the soil health test is so
valuable because it gives us some idea
of what some of those constraints might
be so this is a slide that explains a
little bit the Cornell soil health test
was developed by the Cornell nutrient
analysis lab and there's a whole team of
folks that work on soil health at
Cornell not just agronomist but
horticulturists soil scientists etc and
they came up with the Cornell soil
health assessment training manual which
is right here you can order this online
it's downloadable and it's very helpful
for folks that are just beginning to
understand what soil health could mean
this is the address and the website that
you can get more information about this
process and there's basic packages and
standard packages and the basic is
really for grain and forage crops and
other non agricultural applications
especially used for landscaping and site
remediation but for us with specialty
crops the standard package is what we
are recommending that you get and this
is used a lot in vegetable production
organic producers are very interested in
this information some problem diagnosis
again in landscaping in urban
applications and force for berry crop
growers and tree fruit growers any
especially perennial plant growers the
best time for us to take advantage of
what the soil health test can offer is
for first time soil health assessment
so soil health is the capacity of the
soil to function chemically biologically
and physically and that's what we're
going to explore a little bit and that's
what the soil health test will make sure
that folks understand so characteristics
of healthy soils include good tilth
sufficient but not excessive amounts of
nutrients a sufficient rooting depth
healthy soil has good water storage and
also excellent drainage those are very
important and very crop production it is
free of chemicals that might harm plants
and has relatively low populations of
plant disease and parasitic organisms
but high populations of beneficial
organisms healthy soil has lower weed
pressure and it is has some resistance
to being degraded and all of these help
it become more resilient so it's
actually quick it has a capacity to
recover quickly from adverse events and
those are characteristics of healthy
soil some characteristics or signs of
poor soil health include when you plow
up claudi soul and your poor seed beds
those are signs that you might have poor
soil you might have hard soil at
planting it tends to kind of get that
surface soil hardness on it which is a
real problem there could be rapid onset
or stress or stunted growth during dry
or wet period that's a sign of unhealthy
and poor soil and it can also have poor
growth the vigor on the plants is just
not great at all you might see in poor
soil declining yields that actually is
one of the biggest tip-offs to growers
that there's something happening there
yield just keep going down regardless of
how much fertilizer or organic matter
they might be adding
and that this also can exacerbate high
disease pressure when you get poor vigor
a lot of times diseases take advantage
of that and then that you might see
signs of runoff and erosion so those are
pretty obvious poor soil signs so some
of the interactions and this is what the
soil health test will help delineate or
help make obvious some of the things
that they will indicate to you will have
interaction and so hard soil reduces
rooting but why why does that happen it
could be compacted dense soil layers
restrict rooting volume and then it's
not the plants are not able to exploit
water and nutrients the way they should
be compacted soil can also suppress
beneficial biological processes and so
you see in blue is a physical attribute
and then in green nutrients and root
diseases and denitrification all are
chemical aspects and and the yellow is
the biological so poor drainage reduces
routing and aerobic biological processes
and then the compaction which a hard
soil often you'll have compaction that
will increase root diseases in
denitrification losses so that's an
example of all three of the
characteristics of soil characteristics
having an interaction around hard soil
so some of the things that the Cornell
soil health test will do is that there's
a battery of tests that are employed and
some of these are done in the soil
health the photos of the suite of
analyses the soil physical tests in
power in the blue across the top these
are all laboratory laboratory tests
except the field penetration test and
we'll talk about using that soil penetr
ometer a little bit later and then the
biological tests
are in green across the bottom the soil
health lab uses a modified Morgan
extraction solution to determine soil
nutrient levels and then the soil
texture determination is also used to
catterall categorize test results
Cornell soil have a health test
guidelines and this is just some things
that you'll need in in the field
basically I find that it's easier for me
to take this test if I have an assistant
somebody to help carry some of the gear
but if you're alone you'll definitely
need two five-gallon buckets and one of
them would be for soil we gather much
more soil in this particular test than
you do for a chemical soil analysis you
want a large one gallon ziploc bag to
put all of the soil sample in at the end
of the gathering it you'll want a 600
mil or plastic beaker of three cup
capacity you want a permanent marker and
pen I you a trowel or a spade and I
actually use a larger kind of a tree
spade type thing and that helps a lot to
gather that soil you want a soil penetr
ometer a grower and field information
sheet and a clipboard to hold that
information on and so this right here is
an example of that soil health field
information sheet that you'll be filling
out
so these are rather important guidelines
and the sampling will be done roughly in
the same manner for the standard
chemical soil that the nutrient soil
test with some of these exceptions you
want to sample the soil in the spring
when the soil is at field capacity so
that means that it needs to have enough
soil moisture to be tillable but it
can't be saturated and that is it that
was a difficult thing this spring we had
such a dry April it was difficult to get
any kind of feel capacity in most soils
so and then it started raining like
crazy so it makes it it hard the soil
health test should ideally be done
before tillage occurs and sometimes
that's not an issue in a perennial crop
because we don't do a lot of tillage but
you do want to be aware of that also you
want to have the soil health test
samples gathered before the end of june
because the lab stops analyzing the
samples sometime in july so try to make
the end of june being your kind of
cutoff date if possible you want to use
a trowel or a spade to sample soil as a
larger volume of soils required for this
test again i use kind of a tree spade so
that allows me to gather kind of a nice
sample on that you're going to be making
five stops across the field and you're
going to be again zigzagging kind of in
that W type of random pattern you want
to collect two subsamples samples at
each stop and you're going to mix those
sub-samples thoroughly and then put that
into the bucket at each of those stops
you want to make two penetra meter
readings one from zero to six inches and
then six to 18 inch depth at each
subsample location and actually if we go
back to that form right down here is
this area where you're going to have
push one and push two
surface and then the sub soil samples
and you're going to be doing that for
each of those two locations so you end
up with quite a few readings there then
you're going to record that on the phone
form after you've done this you'll have
at least one and a half or six full cups
and then that's what the three cup
measurement in you want to take that
make sure that you have enough mix that
soil into a ziploc bag label it with the
field name the ID and the date on that
ziplock bag now next you want to make
sure to keep that sample out of direct
sunlight putting it immediately into a
cooler and then if you cannot get this
shipped right away you want to put it in
a cold room or a refrigerator the entire
time that you're shipping so I will
bring a cold pack in my cooler put that
soil sample in there and not let it warm
up the reason being that you don't want
any degradation of organic matter to
happen so just be aware of that it also
makes shipping somewhat difficult
because this is a rather large sample
it's quite heavy and it still needs to
be cool during shipping so going to have
to be aware that you'll need some kind
of a Styrofoam container probably put a
cold pack in if possible so that the
sample can remain cold during shipping
and let your grower clients also know
that you you're going to need to have
some you know they're going to need to
pay for the shipping it is something to
consider especially for doing multiple
samplings so interpreted interpreting
soil health test results make sure to
understand and this is something that I
it took me a while to understand that
the report is a management guide there
is no real hard and fast prescription
but what it does give you are those kind
of readable data so that you can try to
figure out your management around the
data different management approaches can
be used to mitigate the same problem so
that
something that you and the grower would
discuss quite a lot it's why you try to
understand what's the easiest and most
efficient and also economical approach
for the grower in addressing some of the
soil constraints management practices
can affect multiple indicators so some
of your things that you might do like
using cover crops might actually
mitigate many different things and soil
health changes slowly over time one
thing though to be aware of is that we
use this in a vegetable situation we
actually were looking at things back to
back and we actually did see some
improvement even in one year so it is a
long term process often times they won't
see changes but it's wonderful that we
now we have a tool that we can kind of
track these changes when they happen
so here is some here's an example of two
soil health test this is what they look
like we get this kind of we can learn
the effects of long-term mouldboard
ploughing that's what we're looking at
here 14 years of fall plowing if this is
a corn for grain study on a clay loams
loam soil the soil physical properties
have been affected as have the
biological properties a steady diet of
corn stover has maintained soil organic
matter but it's impaired active carbon
levels in the no-till this field started
out as an alfalfa hay and we see that no
tilling maintained a healthy soil which
gives it the high score while the
continuous tulip tillage had measurable
effects and results in the low score and
let me just if i can get my so you can
see that this test on the on the left is
the corn this is the we get aggregate
stability which is in a danger thing
that's the red indicates some danger
available water capacities also in that
red danger zone surface hardness it has
a very excellent rating probably because
of all the tillage that's happening but
the sub surface hardness still you have
a subsurface pan deep compaction
resulting organic matter the yellow
indicates kind of a warning sign it's at
three point nine which is a percentage
it still seems like it should be good
but for some reason it does not rate
that high active carbon is is very poor
their soil biological activities low and
potentially mineralize about nitrogen is
also in that area but the rural health
rating is still quite good so sometimes
some of these things you wonder what
they're there doesn't seem to be a clear
picture across the board in one
biological area soil pH is a little bit
you know from a nutrient or a chemical
aspect 6.1 is a
bad but they put it in the yellow range
extractable phosphorus is a little bit
high probably so that puts that into a
yellow area or caution extractable
potassium is fine and all the your minor
elements are fine but that that rating
gives it a low reading whereas on the
right the same kind of situation but
they've done no till you can see that
all of the aggregate stability the sub
surface hardness the organic matter and
the potentially mineralized will
nitrogen things that were in the red
areas now our green giving it a much
higher rating so the soil health then is
deemed better and we aren't as lucky we
a lot of times we have on no-till
situation just because Barry crops are
primarily no-till so approach for a
successful soil management strategy you
want to assess your soils health to
identify constraints and that's what
we're recommending doing with the
Cornell soil health test you want to be
able to make changes in management
strategies that work for your farm and
that address the specific constraints
identified in the soil health test you
want to be able to experiment on your
farm to see what works in your situation
starting small is helpful and you should
be able to adapt the many resources of
information that you clean from the soil
health test to your farm and build
healthy soils to increase resiliency to
extremes and that's one of the overall
goals and now Kathy is going to talk
about the Cornell tissue analysis or the
or excuse me just tissue analysis in
general thanks Laura we want to take a
look now at the above-ground aspect of
small fruit production and we're going
to look at tissue analysis or leaf
analysis and this kind of testing
directly measures the amount of
nutrients in the leaves and in some
instances as incredible as it may seem
there may be sufficient new tree
in soil and yet leaves can show a
deficiency and we'll talk about the
reasons why that may happen so these
sufficiency ranges have been determined
or estimated for small fruits sometimes
from other crops sometimes directly and
so we'll be looking at those shortly and
these ranges when you fall into the
lower are deficient levels alert you to
nutrient issues that are approaching are
coming and often those can be caught
before they become critical and affect
yield and plant performance these tests
are also used to find to an annual
nitrogen application rates typically
there's a suggested application based on
the crop age but you may need to adjust
in your particular situation either
higher or lower depending on the test
results and then these can also be used
diagnostically as Jeff discussed earlier
to rule out nutritional causes for poor
plant performance
oops sorry wrong way so these tests
could also be done at the agri one lab
and the information for the lab is here
these tests previously were done at
Cornell at the nutrient analysis lab and
they've been shifted to Agri one so that
the nutrient analysis lab can continue
to do the research needed to fine-tune
the recommendations and in this instance
you're looking for the tree fruit and
small fruit form form P and the report
that you will get will give you the
Cornell nutrient guidelines enter and
the interpretation thereof and the
samples run roughly twenty-four dollars
each
so one would you need to collect leaves
for the analysis typically strawberry
leaves are collected after renovation
and we're looking for the first regrowth
the youngest full-size leaves and those
are usually collected toward the middle
to the end of July for blueberries these
leaves are collected just before or
during harvest and you're sampling from
fully expanded mature leaves from the
middle of this year's shoot growth and
those that are exposed to full Sun
typically these are collected in late
July and early August for raspberries
and blackberries you're collecting
leaves from the primer canes and you're
looking for the youngest fully expanded
leaves typically they're collected in
early August one of the things that you
want to remember though is that it's
best to avoid collecting leaves when the
plant resources are all being directed
fully to fruit because in a lot of
instances those levels can fluctuate
there may be sufficient nutrients in the
soil for example but the leaves may show
a deficiency this is particularly true
of potassium so you want to be sure to
try to collect when they're plants
aren't under a heavy fruit load that's
not always possible but try to avoid
that whenever you can so how do we
collect the leaves again we want healthy
leaves that are well exposed to light
they should be representative for the
average condition of the planting try
not to select leaves that are damaged by
disease insects whether for example hail
damaged or mechanical injury don't make
sleeves from different cultivars
remember Jeff talked about management
areas you want to try to keep your
management areas uniform plantings of
different ages leaves from those should
not be mixed those should be separately
sampled and you want a minimum of 2
ounces of fresh weight leaves typically
30 leaves for each sample if possible
try to collect each leaf from a
different plant within the sample area
and then try to process your leaves for
analysis as soon as possible okay when
you prepare your leaves for analysis one
of the things you want to do is use
distilled water for washing and rinsing
the samples washing leaves removes dirt
and residues that can affect the test
results so it's important to do so
before they're dried for shipment so
gently and lightly scrub the leaves
together in distilled water change the
water if it becomes dirty or after eight
to ten samples whichever occurs first
shake the leaves gently to remove excess
water and then rinse the sample and
clean distilled water again shake off
the liquid and rinse with another clean
water sample you can lay these out on
paper towels and let them dry slightly
before you put them in a paper bag and
then you want to leave the top of that
bag open and dry the leaves at room
temperature until they're brittle it's
important not to let the leaves stand in
water you want to try to wash and rinse
them in a minute or less if possible
don't put them in plastic bags to ship
them or ship fresh leaves without drying
because these they often can deteriorate
really rapidly under those conditions
and it will result in very poor test
results
so here's the chart that I was telling
you about where we have the standard
foliar nutrient ranges
and I want you to notice that when you
look for example at strawberries you
have a range where the nutrients are
sufficient and then arrange where they
are deficient below a particular point
and you'll notice across the top the
nitrogen is expressed in percentages
that's true all the way down to boron
and then the the ranges are expressed in
parts per million or ppm and so when we
look at strawberries you'll see that the
range is if you compare those two
raspberries you'll see that for the most
part the ranges are pretty much the same
for these two crops see there's not a
lot of difference between for example
zinc at 20 to 50 ppm and the same for
raspberries in the sufficient range 20
to 50 ppm but when we compare say for
example strawberries or raspberries with
blueberries you will see that
blueberries have significantly lower
levels
the critical values for blueberries are
quite a bit lower they have much lower
nutrient requirements than strawberries
and raspberries one exception to this
however is manganese higher manganese
levels with blueberries is not a problem
as it might be with other crops because
manganese becomes less available as the
pH drops so you can see here blueberries
are able to tolerate manganese even at
the 350 ppm range whereas strawberries
and raspberries prefer a range of 200 or
less
okay it's important to note that not all
labs will compensate for the differences
between say for example strawberries and
raspberries and blueberries in terms of
the blueberries having lower nutrient
requirements and they will often use the
same recommendations that they are using
for strawberries and raspberries with
blueberries because these
recommendations are common across a wide
range of crops and so they may be
recommending add addition of nutrients
in blueberries we're really they aren't
necessary and so that's one of the
things you really need to watch for
okay here's a typical plant tissue
analysis report from farmer in the Dell
and hi ho Dario road these are
blueberries there 1 2 3 years old
they're non bearing and the variety is
liberty and you can see here there's a
knife nice graphic that gives you the
macro and micro nutrients the bar graph
shows when they're in range or when
they're low typically you get the most
benefit when you address nutrient issues
that are falling in the low to deficient
range that's when you really need to
make corrective action when they're in
range or in the high range that's when
typically you won't get a lot of change
in plant performance if you make those
Corrections
and so when we look at this report we
can see that both copper and iron are
deficient zinc is also low however if we
look at the soil levels over here the
levels for those nutrients are adequate
so what would the problem be here if we
go back and look at the soil test
results which is why you want to really
have a paired sample you'll notice that
the pH here is 5.2 which is higher than
you really would like for a blueberry
planting for blueberries you really
would prefer 4.2 to 4.5 when the pH
reaches that level the available
nutrients in the soil will become
available and those deficiencies should
correct themselves without even having
to make an application
so when you're interpreting your results
be sure that the soil pH is within the
correct range assess the status of the
planting to determine if some something
other than nutrients could be limiting
growth for example disease insect
pressure drought other environmental
conditions be sure to check the status
of boron because that has an effect on
other nutrients look for specific
nutrients that may be deficient check
for NRA interactions or imbalances that
exacerbate low nutrient levels and then
come up with your recommendations when
boron levels are low that affects Ruth
growth root growth and development
limiting the uptake of other nutrients
such as calcium and potassium so levels
of these nutrients may be adequate while
leaf levels appear deficient when you
correct the boron levels it will often
correct the issues with the other
nutrients without the need for addition
of supplemental calcium or potassium
another thing to note as we discussed
earlier is that fruiting takes a lot of
potassium so levels of this nutrient may
be adequate while leaf levels appear low
this is especially true as leaf sampling
often occurs not long after fruiting
allowing time for uptake and adequate
irrigation will repent replenish leaf
levels of potassium without the need of
supplementing sometimes high levels of
soil nutrients may also cause problems
for example if phosphorus is too high it
may restrict uptake of micronutrients
such as zinc copper or iron or magnesium
by tying them up in the soil this
frequently occurs in the case of
strawberries another interaction
involves high calcium levels in
blueberry soils this nutrient often ties
up or iron in the soil causing a foliar
deficiency
so when you're interpreting tissue
analysis test results there are some
things to to remember first of all the
test results are not meaningful for
fratelli fertility guidelines unless the
soil pH is within the correct range and
remember that soil test results do not
always correlate with foliar test
results for a variety of reasons so you
may have adequate nutrition in the soil
while there appears not to be adequate
nutrition in the leaves or the reverse
may also be true you may appear to have
adequate nutrition and leaves but not in
soil tissue analysis tests are useful
for diagnosis but not for detailed
guidance unless you consider all of the
factors involved including growth and
yield and applying nutrients may result
in a decrease in foliar concentration
under certain circumstances correcting
deficiencies or imbalances and
established plantings is more difficult
than amending soils prior to planting so
really that pre-plan test and soil
amendment prior to planting is critical
and often provides enough nutrients
especially p and k and the micros for
the life of the planting
nitrogen is something that we need to
add annually and I mentioned that it's
often determined by the crop the plant
age irrigation and mulching status and
the leaf analysis results so often
growers will say okay my strawberry crop
is two years old and so I'm applying 25
pounds per acre of actual nitrogen and
if you actually used your leaf analysis
results in comparison to the crop age
you might find that you had sufficient
nitrogen and you might be able to apply
less or you might find that your
nitrogen is actually lacking and leaves
and you might need to apply more and for
more information on this topic you
should check the Cornell pest management
guidelines for Barry crops to find the
annual rates of nitrogen for your crop
or the N raise production guides for
more in-depth information on adjusting
these to get the proper results
so again in many cases no additional PK
mg or CA will be required if the soil
test recommendations were followed at
planting you may need to supplement k
and potassium and boron especially on
sandier soils because those have a
tendency to leach more quickly and small
amounts of sulfur may be required to
maintain a low pH in some soils where
blueberries are grown especially if
calcium levels are approaching 2000 leaf
analyses provides guidance on
supplemental fertilizers after the
planning established and don't rely on a
soil test for post plant recommendations
that do not involve soil pH remember the
pH has to be at the correct range
so in review don't rely on visual
symptoms of what you've always done in
the past in terms of very soil nutrient
management if you want to maximize your
yield and plant health before you plant
consider doing the Cornell soil health
test which includes the standard
chemical soil test and more the physical
and biological properties that Laura
discussed and then after plants are
established use annual tissue analysis
and soil testing every two to three
years to fine-tune your nutrient plan
that's the end of our presentation today
and we'd like to acknowledge dr. Marvin
prince who's the project leader of our
project he's a professor and chair of
the Department of Horticulture at
Cornell University you've already met
Laura Jeff and myself we'd also like to
thank Mario Miranda zazo one of our team
members whose with the tree fruit and
berry fruit extensions he's tree fruit
very extension specialist with cornell
extension lake ontario fruit team mr.
dan welch who's extension resource
educator with Cayuga County Cooperative
Extension dr. Harold Burness who's
professor in at Cornell University in
the Department of crop and soil sciences
who works very extensively with the
Cornell soil health program and mr.
Robert shindle back whose extension
associate also in the same department
and is the coordinator of the Coronel
soil health testing and we have special
thanks to mrs. Janet Fallon with Agri
one she's the certified crop adviser and
was very helpful in providing
information for this presentation thank
you
you